this is Larissa which has become such a
sort of fulcrum a focus after this crash
in fact the hospital is just down Road
this is actually Larissa train station
and the passengers try and carrying
about a 350 people
this was its last stop uh on its Journey
before that fateful moment when it
emerged from uh from a tunnel just
outside at Larissa City and went head-on
into a freight train now it's hard to
think of a more fundamental failing when
it comes to public transport than two
trains on the same line going in
opposite directions add to that the the
informed speculation is that the
passenger train was probably doing
around 100 miles an hour possibly more
the freight train coming in the other
direction would have been doing a lower
speed but that combined uh speed when
they Clash would have been horrendous
which of course explains the devastation
that that you are seeing at The Crush
site carriages that have been toppled
over that have rolled flipped thrown in
the air after that that collision and
then the fire that engulfed some of
those carriages suggestions that
temperature would have gone beyond a
thousand degrees Centigrade we know that
there are 36 people dead that there are
many more than that who are in hospital
but frankly we don't know where the
number of dead will reach still
suggestions that there are still people
who are being being pulled from that
wreckage and a lot of a lot of sadness
recrimination and a small amount of
anger Brewing as well I was in this city
Square in front of the train station a
vigil has been held several hundred
people here lighting candles in memory
of those who've who've died also worth
noting that this station is not just the
focus of this story it is also the focal
point of the criminal investigation
because just actually a matter of hours
after this crush the station Master here
was arrested by police and has already
been charged with a number of criminal
offenses including multiple accounts of
death by negligence effectively
manslaughter and other negligence
charges what I think we can read into
that is that authorities are holding him
responsible for allowing these two
trains to be on the same line now on the
one hand you may consider well that if
somebody is in charge of signaling then
de facto they must be responsible but
when I talk to that anger and that sense
of recrimination there are plenty here
plenty across Greece who have
immediately he said well we told you
something like this would happen why
well because the Greek rail network is
chronically underfunded it simply does
not have the kind of sophisticated
signaling system that we take for
granted in the United Kingdom and
frankly in most of uh in most of Europe
the signaling system was supposed to be
upgraded on this line years ago that has
never happened and so work is done
manually and the rail regulator in its
last report actually highlighted this as
a danger and said that this system was
prone to human error one of the rail
unions itself a month ago warned of the
possibility of a really significant
Crush like this so I think you've got
two strands you've got a criminal
investigation which is clearly blaming
the station master and then this other
popular sentiment that's something more
profound uh caused this crash but of
course above it all is the simple
horrible human tragedy of dozens of
people dying and many more who are badly
injured and the prospect that more
people could be about to lose their
lives and what is Greece's worst rail
disaster in living memory and Europe's
worst rail crash for a decade